qui est actuellement en quarantaine un
mois bon en ce moment niveau ambiance
pas ou pas ouf on a déjà connu mieux
nous sommes en guerre enfin ça y est on
est tous ceux en quarantaine en
confinement chez nous interdit de sortir
sauf putra nécessité voilà pourquoi je
suis une petite vidéo depuis mon chez
moi tout seul son équipe pas depuis mon
institut habituel moi je vais faire la
vidéo à ma place c'est trop petit là il
manque juste un mètre 55 rue de pau à
bouger mon pied n'est pas de souci cette
situation est complètement ouf pas se
rendirent est aussi un petit peu
angoissante mais voilà pas non plus être
parano
[Musique]
mon père par exemple toi et vit seul il
en bas de chez lui mais quand même il
désinfecte tous les jours toutes les
poignées de porte de chez lui au cas où
le niveau secure il est au max et c'est
une très bonne chose pour déstresser
c'est normal on est tous à la maison on
a un à faire on passe notre temps devant
la télé ou les réseaux à ingurgiter les
mêmes muse anxiogène non-stop jusqu'à
overdose et éthiques
je peux avoir un peu en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce qu'on a de mieux à
faire c'est de rester à la maison chez
soi franchement on dirait que dans un
film de science fiction mais dans lequel
il y aurait très peu d'actions à zombie
vacances pour suis né dans un monde en
train de sombrer un virus est en
extension permanente une catastrophe qui
pourrait détruire l'humanité
heureusement on peut la sauver en
faisant la vaisselle en dormant en
regardant des tricks et surtout en
allant à la boulangerie en ayant
préalablement mandri un petit formulaire
je suis chez moi par le producteur de il
est chez lui
bientôt au cinéma enfin quand on aura le
droit d'y aller quoi d'ailleurs ce
formulaire
on en parle ou pas à chaque fois que je
sors de chez toi faut vraiment avoir une
bonne raison
ça fout une pression douce et et vous
moi quel est votre motif de
l'attestation annoncé que je les attends
je vais sur mon point qu on attendait
truc ultra salah en plus un peu flou
parce que quand t'as pas d'imprimante
chez toi tu dois écrire à la main
l'autorisation sur l'honneur en
autorisant toi même que tu peux sortir
ok donc je m'autorise moi même les
affronts prix pour acheter
un kinder ping oui alors il parait que
les étrangers étaient choqués de notre
non coopération face à la pandémie
et j'avoue que je sais pas si on est un
peuple genre un peu rebelle ou juste b
et le message ne voulait pas passer le
mot d'ordre est clair
restez chez vous moi je sors de chez moi
non on a dit pour sauver des vies il
faut rester chez vous sinon c'est hyper
égoïste emmène moi ce soir encore de ces
mois vous allez devoir payer 135 euros
veut fille témoin veut fille témoin
attaques venues des mois netflix lci je
passe c'est parce qu'il ya eu un petit
moment de panique générale
on va tous mourir mais dès qu'on nous
dit un truc dans les médias on dirait
que tout le monde fait strictement
l'inversé on nous dit de ne pas sortir
de chez nous l'action des français on
dit qu'il n'y aura pas de pénurie de
nourriture réaction des français
en tout cas qu'on le veuille ou non
maintenant on est vraiment en
quarantaine j'avoue que en quarantaine
très vite tu commences un pas chercher
moi j'ai commencé à me faire chier au
bout de fallait une heure par tu te fais
chier ici c'est chez ici tu fais ch est
là aussi
là on sent bien pas mal je me fais
tellement chez que j'ai carrément créer
un compte tic toc d'ailleurs abonnez
vous en plus pour couronner le tout la
seule fois de ma vie où je suis re plus
obligatoirement à la maison pendant
longtemps je n'ai pas internet
ça me fout un seul vous imaginez même
pas et là vous dit comment il a mis en
ligne sa vidéo j'utilise le partage de
connexion de mon téléphone mais c'est
archi moyens franchement s'il ya bien un
truc que j'aurais kiffé faire en période
de confinement c'est vraiment de jouer
pendant des heures à des jeux en ligne
en profiter pour ce traîné et tout
impossible à la plage doit jouer à des
jeux en partage des eaux qui prennent
très peu de débit quoi j'ai pris une
dose d gaming mecque et charles tremble
encore en plus quand tu es enfermé en
confinement en couple ou avec juste une
personne c'est un peu compliqué de
s'engueuler ou de se faire la gueule
c'est quoi je me bats gérés à temps
alors j'ai un peu ce foot et les réseaux
comme tout le monde tu vois il ya des
gens qui croient vraiment être dans le
film seul sur mars c'est fondé story
genre ok journal de bord toujours un
confinement jour 3 aujourd'hui je me
suis réveillé je me suis fait un petit
café et comme à bages et qui fait je
pense que je vais m'en faire un deuxième
disons que dans le film seul sur mars
le mec qui fait un journal de bord en
vidéo et c'est intéressant parce que
bayer sur mars toi tu étais sur terre en
l'occurrence à roubaix donc arrête alors
j'avoue je suis très jaloux des gens qui
vivent à la campagne dans des maisons
avec des jardins et tout en plus il fait
super beau et tout la fête se regardent
leur story tu fais mal mais qu'il en
quarantaine ou en vacances là c'est
clairement mille fois plus nulle d'être
à paris ou en tout cas dans les grandes
villes comme par hasard en ce moment il
fait super bon mais personne ne peut
sortir et continuent de mettre la météo
à la télé quoi alors à toulouse
grand soleil que vous allez voir à
travers vos fenêtres puisque vous êtes
en confinement en bretagne un soleil ses
limites l'été vous allez tout raté sinon
dans le vaucluse
heureusement pendant cette période un
petit peu bas dante franchement lemmerz
et les plus tôt vous êtes juste trop
drôle j'ai vu des trucs ça m'a tué je
crois que toutes les blagues possible
sur la situation ont été faites je vous
ai carrément fait une petite sélection
de ce qu'il m'a fait marrer
bon on a le temps on s'est tous un petit
peu j'ai donc je voulais londres patron
qui me remercie d'être venus travailler
aujourd'hui mois testés positifs au
super bowl gouvernement il faut adopter
des gestes barrières au cours d'un virus
français chjami ciel pur jus d'orange
mamie qui pourrait garder les enfants
ces prochains jours très drôle un peu
agressif j'aime beaucoup c'est vrai que
garder ses enfants enfermés pendant une
très longue période c'est un mix entre
paradis et enfer plus de coiffeur flûte
sephora plus de city sienne les vraies
attentes la semaine mais ya pas de genre
[ __ ] les mecs et les meufs aussi aller
moi cette barre de 3 jours tôt quand on
demande de se munir d'un masque et de
gel mais que t'as pas bien compris moi
c'est pour la salle de sexe en fait j'ai
terminé youporn mois six jours un jour
huit jours 23
tu veux que je te met un coup de tête
petit jo 26 août avait prévenu margot
voilà c'est pour qu'il dit un hors jeu
traduit l'anglais qu'au niveau de
sixième mois 2020 ça craint impossible
ça devienne pire avril dit à wral même
au plus fort de la panique au
supermarché personne ne veut des pizzas
à l'ananas 29.0 tweet world en train de
sombrer mail
ça c'est mon bref baby sitters after
intervention de macron c'est tellement
vrai conclusion il faut arrêter de
manger les pangolins indigeste animal il
ya deux mois il n'existait pas on dirait
qu'on viens de l'inventer
on dirait un nouveau pokémon pas ça
drôle mais pour de vrai pas de manger ça
quoi regardez bien cette photo est ce
que ça c'est appétissant nom dessus tout
est dégueulasse l'assiette la nappe le
contenu tout imagine tu vas chez un pote
le mec te sert sa [ __ ] non maintenant
les conclusions être en quarantaine
c'est vraiment le truc le plus simple au
monde pour sauver des vies quoi en run
off ya pas plus simple et chez toi tu
épouses
il ya des gens qui sont sauvées grâce à
ce à quoi en plus dans cette situation
on a vraiment le meilleur rôle quoi moi
je profite de ma famille à fond
j'espère que vous pouvez le faire vous
aussi donc restez chez vous on ne dira
jamais assez c'est hyper important on
envoie tout notre soutien aux infirmiers
aux infirmières au corps médical aux
médecins urgentistes je connais pas tous
les rôles mais j'imagine même pas
comment ils doivent être débordés on
vous envoie notre force notre courage
d'ailleurs prouvé comme pas mal de
français les applaudir tous les soirs à
vos fenêtres à 20 heures hyper classe de
faire ça je trouve même si tu habites
seule dans un champ
il prend pas entendre mais le coeur y
est évidemment penser aussi aux familles
des victimes et aux gens qu'ils seront
encore sous traitement force à vous
aussi
ok journal de bord j'ai fini le message
du jour j'espère que vous avez aimé
mettez un petit pouce en l'air si vous
avez apprécié abonnez vous à ma chaîne
youtube et cliquez sur la cloche pour
être notifié des prochaines vidéos on
sera très bientôt terminée
[Musique]